[Música]
y
en borgoña no solamente se habla de uvas
la otra fruta estrella de la región es
la grosella
todo un sector se ha organizado
alrededor de esta pequeña valla
[Música]
actualmente esta apreciada fruta negra
es transformada de muchas formas
[Música]
su uso más conocido es la célebre
producción del licor de dijon
los coristas producen 16 millones de
botellas al año para una facturación
total de 60 millones de euros
un puñado de empresas se reparte en el
mercado en borgoña
es en esta fábrica de edición que la
marca de diego yo fabrica la preciada
crema de grosella cada año la empresa
usa más de 1000 toneladas de esta
pequeña valla negra
vamos a sacar cuántas 15 toneladas hoy
hay 19 toneladas que llegan entonces
haremos cerca de 25 o 30 hoy el mercado
francés representa la mayoría de las
ventas aún pero el elite agulló creó una
nueva receta especialmente para el
mercado alemán
esto de alemania es de la semana pasada
entonces esto fue hecho la semana pasada
la tirada está prevista para la próxima
semana más o menos 20.000 botellas
en total los vi coristas de borgoña
exportan al extranjero 6 millones de
botellas al año
el desarrollo de una marca que tiene
vocación internacional es evidentemente
la exportación hoy en día es
efectivamente la posibilidad de poder
desarrollar no sólo la crema de grosella
edition sino también la presentación
detallada de las otras cremas y también
el vestimos como gran bretaña o estados
unidos incluso asia por supuesto
la ciudad de dijon enarbola con orgullo
el color de la grosella pero también
posee un museo donde turistas del mundo
entero pueden descubrir la especialidad
de la región cada año los empleados del
museo revelan los secretos del
tradicional licor a cerca de 40 mil
personas en
línea sólo hay grosellas alcohol y
azúcar nada más en la botella es apenas
debajo
para estos jóvenes canadienses más
acostumbrados al jarabe de arce que a la
crema de grosella el descubrimiento
puede ser sorprendente
cada una puede tomar un vaso pueden
degustar
nunca antes había probado pero cuando
regrese trataré de conseguir no está mal
este licor
podríamos poner licor de grosella en
helado de vainilla sería muy rico pero
también solo beberlo lo es también
un éxito a la medida de este producto
que hoy en día se volvió uno de los
emblemas del patrimonio regional
todo comenzó a principios del siglo 20
cuando los licoristas de dijon
desarrollan la producción luego es en un
eclesiástico diputado alcalde de dijon
el canónigo félix kirk que le dará su
nombre a un aperitivo hecho con vino
blanco y crema de grosella a partir de
ahí despegó el sector
[Música]
hacia el mundo entero no bebía que poco
a poco la reputación del canónigo hizo
que la viviéramos un poco por todas
partes
actualmente los habitantes de dijo-
recuerdan al canónigo que así su
apellido se ha conocido en el mundo
entero
a 30 kilómetros al sur de dijon la finca
biológica tribus trabaja la grosella de
otra forma
aquí no hay licor sino mermeladas y
productos un poco más sorprendentes
en las ollas de cobre una salsa de
grosella
fue un giro muy importante en la finca
frijoles porque es un producto que
cuando lo sacamos en el 2005 explotó en
términos de volumen yo pensaba fabricar
300 tarros para divertirme hoy en día es
un producto fabricamos miles de tarros
cada año
una pequeña parte de su cosecha es
vendida en especial a grandes
restaurantes
instruye en este restaurante con
estrellas michelín se usa también el
sabor de esta fruta puede ser cocinado
con todas las salsas
[Música]
el chef hace por ejemplo un filete de
pato con néctar jalea y yemas de
grosella
entonces usted
y agrego puré de agua turba de grosella
evidentemente su primer uso es para los
postres los sorbetes los helados y luego
en los salados porque es una fruta un
sabor que va muy bien con pollo o carne
en la sala este sutil acuerdo logra la
adhesión de los clientes
le voy a decir es muy bueno la grosella
la conocía sobre todo en el kids pero en
cocina es diferente
la gastronomía no es el único sector de
futuro para la grosella
la yema de la planta es cada vez más
utilizada en cosméticos y productos
farmacéuticos
el futuro es radiante para la grosella
de borgoña
[Música]